- It's time to make some meatballs
'cause what's more Italian
than some meatballs.
(meatball whooshing)
Hey, everyone, I'm Chef Joe Sasto.
And today, I'm going to be turning
one of these mystery
ingredients into pasta.
Well, we have some crazy options here.
Let's find out what I'm making today.
(wheel clacking)
All right, a Chipotle burrito.
I'm okay with that one,
that's not too hard.
It's not the easiest option on here.
Let's just get started.
I think first things first, we
need to order some Chipotle.
(doorbell ringing)
And we have our Chipotle.
So we got the whole thing.
Obviously, some chips,
salsas, we'll include those.
I have some ideas, the ideas are flowing.
I know how to work those
into the mix, right.
We got a healthy portion
of crema. Thank goodness.
'Cause that actually is my favorite part,
and wow, a very tiny burrito.
Am I crazy? Didn't they used
to be much bigger than this?
Let's open this up.
We'll give it a little, a
quick bite, a taste test.
(upbeat music)
Okay, we've got steak, beans and rice.
I have all these on the side.
I'll use everything. Just to keep it fair.
This is gonna be good. I know what to do.
We got this, let's make some pasta.
First things first, we
need our pasta dough.
Now I've never done this before.
Obviously, I've made quite
a bit of pasta dough,
but my instincts tell me to
use the rice in the dough.
So we're gonna go our
burrito rice into here.
I'm gonna to give it
a little bit of flour,
just to get it started.
I'm using double zero and semolina.
A little of this, a little of that.
(food processor whirring)
I got just a little bit of
room temperature water here.
All right, that is the
beginning of our pasta dough.
I am gonna use the rest of this flour,
and the rest of this flour.
And of course, you know,
a little bit of salt.
It goes a long way, making
everything taste better.
Slowly adding in some water.
Voila! Huh? How bout that?
Who would've thought you can turn
Chipotle burrito rice into pasta dough.
Time to knead,
I'm gonna take just a
little bit of flour here,
just to make sure we're not gonna stick.
I already could tell right now,
I'm gonna use this to make some cavatelli.
I don't think that's
ever been done before.
First time ever things are happening here,
and you're watching it.
You're part of it.
Pasta dough is done.
Let's get this wrapped up
and break down the rest of that burrito
for the rest of our pasta.
So I need to incorporate the
burrito tortilla here some way.
So I'm just gonna go ahead
and cut this into some thin strips.
So butter is hot, nice, and sizzling.
We'll come in with our tortilla strips.
A little pinch of salt
and our chipotle powder
for our Chipotle burrito.
Chipotle, smoked dried jalapenos
for anyone out there that was wondering.
Most chilies have two names,
a name when they're fresh and
a name when they're dried.
Interestingly enough.
So I'm just going to
let my crumble rumble.
I'm going to throw this into the oven,
let it get nice and crispy.
And then it's time to make some meatballs
because what's more Italian
then some meatballs.
So I have my steak here
from my Chipotle burrito.
We'll start with a little bit
of olive oil, some onions.
We'll start with a little sofrito here,
diced onions, some chopped garlic.
We'll sweat this down.
Onions and garlic cooked down.
Nice, soft and translucent.
And we'll go in with all that steak.
I got a little bit of smoked paprika here.
Let's just toss this all together.
Toss, toss, toss. That
looks and smells awesome.
So I'm going to let
this cool in the fridge.
I'm going to grab more tortilla chips
and then we're going to
turn it all into meatballs.
I want to grind these
down into bread crumbs.
Except it's not bread,
they're going to be tortilla
chip crumbs for our meatballs.
I'm probably only going to
use, eh, we'll use that many.
All right, so steak now
into our tortilla crumbs.
Into here instead of ground beef.
Now we need, uh let's see, an egg.
This is going to be our binder,
hold everything together.
We're on our way.
Look at that. That is meatballish.
Taste test. Make sure
we like our seasoning.
Gloves on. Time to form some meatballs.
I'm going to use a little scoop here,
just to keep things nice and consistent.
Now I'm just going to come through here,
make these all nice and pretty.
The true testament of this is at the end,
when we're tasting it.
If they can't tell that we
started with a Chipotle burrito,
I think we accomplished our mission.
A little more olive oil into a hot pan.
There's no raw meat in here.
So really I just want to
crisp them up on the outside.
Get a little bit of color.
We're just going to let these guys
finish cooking all the way through,
and then we're cooking some pasta.
For a sauce,
I'm going to incorporate the pinto beans
that I had picked out of
my burrito from earlier.
I'm also going to supplement that
with a little bit of vegetables over here.
Starting with a hot saute pan,
we're going to go in with a
couple of tablespoons of butter.
Butter makes things taste better.
Melt that down, bring it together.
We have some diced onion.
We've got some diced carrot.
Ready to incorporate our beans.
And then we have this pico to use, right?
So we'll do a little bit
of that tomato in there.
Toss that all together to combine.
And then I do want to kind
of cook this down together,
make this all become one.
This is a beef stock.
And so I'm just going to cover everything
with a little bit of stock.
We'll bring this up to a simmer,
reduce it just a little bit,
and then we're going to
throw it all into the blender
till it's nice and smooth.
So our bean ragu has
reduced to about half here.
Now I just want to blend it all together,
and we'll have a nice,
smooth and creamy bean sugo.
(blender whirring)
Let's give it a little
taste test for approval.
We're nice and smooth creamy.
Oh! No one's going to know
this is a Chipotle burrito.
I don't even know it's a Chipotle burrito.
I'm going to see this up
with just a little squirt of lime juice.
And it's time to roll out some pasta.
I'm going to just going
to divide this into,
let's call it sixths.
I know math is hard.
Then those will be ready.
I'm going to come in here and
take each strip and roll it.
Might need the spray bottle.
There we go. Now we're rolling.
I'm Italian. I'm allowed
to do this, right?
So those are all done.
I got all of my snakes finished.
Going to take my flour now and
just dust that over the top.
So snakes are together. Then
we can come in with our cutter.
I like to go in half and go down the row.
Pasta magic happening
right before your eyes.
That's not it. Now we have
all of our cavatelli, almost.
Then you come in here and I'm
gonna use a cavarola board,
just to put a little bit of
texture and that notorious
little cup on each piece of pasta.
And then we're on to the moment of truth,
we've all been waiting for.
Time to cook this and
bring it all together.
So we got all of our rice,
Chipotle cavatelli noodles.
One of a kind, maybe the one and only time
this will ever be done.
Perfect, lid back on.
So where you're boiling.
So noodles are floating here.
We'll give it a little-.
Much more fluffy then
I would have imagined.
Really nice texture on those.
That's pleasant. I liked that.
What a fun surprise, huh?
Our noodles are done.
Into our meatball pan.
A little bit of that pasta water.
Always our friends, some starchy water.
We call that the white gold.
I have our bean sugo from earlier.
Will go one nice spoonful of that.
And now, hear that sound?
Sound of good pasta my friends, huh?
We'll go pasta down
first. In our bean ragu.
Let's go crema. Crema is next.
Oh my, look at that.
Next, our meatballs.
Next, a little bit of our
cilantro for freshness.
We have our crispy
crumbly tortilla strips.
What a beautiful looking bowl of pasta,
made from a Chipotle burrito.
Now we just got to bring
in our taste tester.
Alex, welcome.
- I'm back!
- You're back.
- For more.
- I have another pasta here for you.
- Oh!
- Smell Test.
- Smells great. Kind of smells like beans.
- You're good. Yes.
Yes. There you're on the right track.
I like this.
- Okay, gotta get some
pasta. Gotta get some sauce.
- You're a good bite
builder. That's a good bite.
- This tastes like Mexican food
- Yes. You're on the right track.
It's fast food.
- Like a burrito bowl?
- Close. I mean it's a
burrito from Chipotle.
- Oh (bleep)
- Yes.
- You're a star.
You're so creative
- Thank you for watching.
I want to know, let me
know in the comments,
what I should make into pasta next.
- Can I eat it?
- And we'll have Alex here forever to try.
- (Indistinct)
- The ultimate judge.
- I'm okay with being a judge.
- Oh, yes.
(upbeat jazz music)